رحله الشتاء عاده سنويا لاهالي عسير البحث
عن المناطق الدافئه يتوجه الكثير من
الاهالي لنزول الى تهامه للاستمتاع
بالاجواء الدافئه والهروب من درجات
الحراره المنخفضه محمد خالد مع التفاصيل
[موسيقى]
في فصل الشتاء يتوجه الكثير من اهالي
منطقه عسير لنزول الى تابه الى الاستمتاع
بالاجواء الدافئه والهروب من درجات
الحراره المنخفضه واللي تكونت عاده اشتهرت
بين اهالي عسير من زمان وهي رحله الشتاء
والصيف
[موسيقى]
في كل شتاء يجتمع على اصدقاء والاهالي في
رحله عسير الاشعار في هذا التقرير راح
نوصلت الضوء على ابرز العادات و الطقوس
اللي اتخذها الاهالي في هذه الرحله
[موسيقى]
فصلنا الاشهر الاماكن في طبخ المنزل واللي
توهدها لاهالي وتشهد ازدحام وتوابير كثيره
في اغلب اختها وخصوصا في نهايه عطله
الاسبوع الفقره بالتحديد ما راح احد يقدر
يستغني عنها لانها شيء اساسي يكون محبين
الاكل واللي مسوي دايت الله يعيده
ده الواحد اللي ينزل مع العقبه لازم يمر
في الفتره الثانيه الحقيقه اللي ما ينزل
هذا الوقت من اهالي منطقه عسير او غيرها
ولا يمر المندي
ما كنا نزل
[موسيقى]
انبسط
انا وعيالي للثانس
اي واحد ينزل هنا منصور الجوزين
والاكسجين زين كلها طيبه الحمد لله
واجهه بحريه فلذات نغير درجه حراره من
8-7 الى 25 26
[موسيقى]
بحريه في المملكه
وصلنا محطتنا الاخيره واجهت عسير البحريه
التي تعتبر اكبر واجهه بحريه في المملكه
في هذا المكان يجتمعون الاهالي للاستمتاع
بالاجواء البحريه والصيد والكثير من
الطقوس اللي في السهو الاحاري اجواء
نقلناها لكم تميز رحله الشتاء في عسير
محمد خالد العربيه